ينطلق سباق الملياردير في الفضاء من ريتشارد
برانسون وجيف بيزوس
ليكونا أول من ينطلق
إلى الفضاء من خلال رحلات السياحة الفضائية الخاصة
بهما.
تكساس في الذكرى السنوية الـ 52
للهبوط على سطح القمر
، يبدو أن قطب الأمازون قد تخطى
برانسون
الذي اعتقد الكثيرون أنه سيفوز في هذا السباق
باع
28 مليونًا وهذا هو المبلغ الذي
يدفعه عارض غير معروف ليكون جزءًا من
التاريخ ويأخذ رحلة 11 دقيقة إلى الفضاء
مع بيزوس
إنه شيء كنت أرغب في القيام به طوال
حياتي ، وسينضم إلى الملياردير أيضًا
شقيقه مارك بيزوس ،
وأريدك حقًا أن تأتي معي ،
هل أنت جاد
وأنا مسافر رابع مجهول ،
الرحلة عبارة عن رحلة شبه مدارية و  الذهاب
إلى الفضاء لمسافة 100 كيلومتر فقط
مما يسمح للعملاء بالحصول على حوالي ثلاث
دقائق من انعدام الوزن
، وبينما يتصدر بيزوس
عناوين الأخبار الآن ،
فإن شعار فيرجن جالاكتيك هو  أن تكون
أول خط فضاء تجاري في العالم ،
هل يبدو الأمر
كما لو أن فيرجن لن تكون أنت تعرف الأول
وأن الأصل الأزرق قد يفوز بهذا الجزء
من هذا السباق ،
سأشير إلى أننا أرسلنا الآن
سبعة  سبعة أشخاص
إلى الفضاء وقد جعلنا
خمسة رواد فضاء جدد تعرفونهم ، كنا
أول شركة من شركات الفضاء توصل
الناس إلى هناك ،
لكننا بصراحة لا نرى ذلك حيث قام
برانسون بتغريد تهنئته
إلى بيزوس.  في خطط رحلاتهم الفضائية ،
أخبرت شركة Virgin galactic CNN أثناء استمرارها
في المسار الصحيح لإنهاء عمليات الاختبار النهائية ،
أنها لم تحدد موعد إطلاق رسمي ،
حيث قامت شركتا الفضاء
برحلات اختبار شبه مدارية ناجحة على مدار العقد الماضي ، تعرضت شركة
Virgin galactic لانتكاسة في عام 2014
عندما  قُتل مساعد الطيار خلال رحلة تجريبية
لطراز سابق لمركبتهما
الفضائية ،
لكن الشركة باعت منذ ذلك الحين حوالي 600
تذكرة بأكثر من
200000 لكل منها ، وهي تكلفة من المرجح أن ترتفع
حتى الآن لأقل من 600 شخص هكتار.
لقد ذهبنا إلى الفضاء وسواء كانت هذه الرحلة الأولى من بيزوس أو برانسون ،
فمن المؤكد أن هذه الرحلة الأولى ستطلق نوعًا جديدًا
من السياحة
مما يسمح لأولئك الذين يمكنهم تحمل
السعر والأدرينالين يندفعون إلى
مجموعتهم الخاصة من أجنحة رواد الفضاء
وحقوق التباهي مدى الحياة
rachel crane cnn new york